[Música]
nós vivemos mais tempo agora do que em
qualquer período da história
há 150 anos a esperança de vida era
mesmo os países mais desenvolvidos da
altura 40 anos
agora é mais de 80 anos e somente hoje
virada para cima tudo do combate às
doenças infecciosas
graças a avanços na tecnologia na
medicina como os antibióticos sua vez
resultaram uma diminuição dramática na
mortalidade infantil que é um dos
grandes trunfos de tecnologia da
civilização
além disso são os avanços e progressos e
vão tecnológico a nível ter diminuição
da pobreza e falta uma maior racha na
atualidade
este é o melhor tempo para se viver no
futuro um promete ser um momento
promissor
no entanto algumas coisas permanecem
inalteradas na unidade por exemplo nossa
vida nós achamos que temos e quando
atingem a idade adulta começamos
realmente rendimento tirar pensamos em
vencer o processo de envelhecimento é um
processo gradual aumento da
vulnerabilidade e diminuição da via
terminado que afeta todos os órgãos do
nosso corpo
o processo de envelhecimento é tão igual
que moraram anos atrás a maioria de nós
a maioria das pessoas no mundo vai
morrer de uma das doenças associadas com
o crescimento com o campo que essa
neurose nativas com doenças
cardiovasculares e filho o momento não
gerada
nós temos um aumento na porcentagem de
pessoas idosas e comente um aumento
dramático nas doenças crônicas e nas
suas associadas com o crescimento pois o
crescimento é um dos grandes disse
e os do século 21 nós precisamos de
combater o envelhecimento mesmo fala com
combatemos os trânsitos infecciosas para
no futuro temos vidas em de melhor e nós
podemos já controlar o aquecimento a
menos em animais são cielo que a edição
pequenas minha profissão e animais
microscópicos que vivem apenas algumas
semanas mas que é surpreendente é que
nós conseguimos manipular o investimento
nesses animais
o envelhecimento é surpreendentemente
forte que me amam a cintura da genética
nós vemos a tragédia nestes animais que
controlam o crescimento continuam vamos
virar forma dramática
nós conseguimos dar um só gene e
aumentaram a china na terceira e mais
dez vezes em vez de viver em algumas
semanas fiz em vários meses
- nós conseguimos controlar o
crescimento nós conseguimos alterar ou
sugerem ratinhos e aumentar a actividade
cerca de 50 por cento ou seja a taxa que
confirmamos fazer em seres humanos
seremos a viver todos mais 150 anos e é
importante mencionar que quando nós
aumentamos a longevidade em animais
enfim de ratinhos não só aumentar o
tempo vira tentamos aumentar o tempo de
vida com souza
ou seja os ratinhos ainda desenvolvem
doenças e não vou morrer mas envolvem
essas doenças mais tarde na vida
ou seja nós temos a aumentar o período
em que os embolsou o que queremos fazer
em seus menus
nós temos pessoas com 70 anos tenham
souza pessoas com 50 anos
é claro que são mais complexas
sabemos que o impacto fiscal vida mas a
gente também são importantes
já a romã é um exemplo de respeito do
sul frança pelo 122 antes a pessoa mais
idosa que há registo de 1 55 impactos
nec
se um jornalista os ingressos para eu
viver 120 anos é que eu deixei de fumar
quando fiz em 2010 o que tem algum
fundamento porque é um filme ou é grande
parte da vida adulta dela só pro fumar
continua bastante tons e visão dela com
sua falhar
ela tinha medo de magoar com cigarro
eu estava muito bem no porto enquanto
não tem um estilo de vida resultando na
o que nós associamos a pessoa mais velha
de sempre levam sabemos que há gente que
impacton é uma atividade e sabemos que
alguns também portanto é importante
inferiores
vocês querem viver mais 100 anos é
importante escolher bem os nossos pais e
avós pois nós sabemos que é um
componente genético vão à vida humana
apesar de nós sabemos todos os chefes ou
exatamente quais são os mecanismos mas
felizmente a tecnologia que está se
desenvolvendo em anos recentes
transmitem-se frangos nó mesmo
tecnologias concessão tenha uma foto
minha fingir que será que aquela máquina
faixa
o que é mas com esta e outras nos
permitem seqüenciando o genoma de uma
forma muito mais barata e muito mais
rápida
vocês podem se conhece a voz calma
primeiras mil euros e conseguiu três
vitórias nos afazeres conhece anos no
centenário meus tentar perceber quais
são os genes associados com com edson
voz virada com as chances do manchester
animais são resistentes a doenças como
por exemplo que a lei é muito alto em
outras propriedades extraordinárias
podem ser muito resistente o cancro são
pequenos roedores mas viver mais 30 anos
quando já tinha tudo e vivem 34 anos e
tem uma incidência tempo muito baixa
pois nós conhecemos os nomes desses
animais vemos todos os gênios do dna
desses animais
tentamos descobrir genes estejam
associados com a proteção campo
estamos também porque mesmo ter pressão
dna kansas cortamos dna estão associados
com o envelhecimento
estamos também animais fiquem ainda mais
tempo que nós como colaborou tânia
cristina consigam viver mais de 200 anos
o que é fantástico que vivem em estado
selvagem não têm médicos pois nós
conhecemos numa terça animais mais uma
vez tentam descobrir alterações sutis no
dna
posso explicar a sua voz virada porque
tentamos descobrir gênios os produtos
cujas proteínas tenham pequenas
operações que alcancem a sua função
experimentam resistir a doenças ao homem
do campo
passámos o campo é uma célula começar a
leccionar forma sem controlo que mais
têm duas vezes mais chances do que nós
isto fosse igual teria um campo melhor
muito jovem mas não tem os r 1.200 antes
pois tem que ter mecanismos naturais
g o cancro e outras doenças do
envelhecimento e é isso que nós tentamos
descobrir a inclusive animais que
apresentam não envelhecer todo
tanto quanto sabemos todos mamíferos
envelhecem existem animais com um certo
tipo de testes práticos portugal sete
tipos falantes que prendam não
envelhecer mostra que o investimento não
é nem oficial nem inevitável e natureza
expansão natural consegue envolver um
investimento consegue combater as
doenças pois não há nenhum motivo para
pensar que nós não podemos fazer o mesmo
não conseguimos ultrapassar o nosso
limite psicológico através da tecnologia
e isso nós estamos a tentar fazer tentar
perceber o que é que antes o único o dna
centenários ratos toupeiras goiás e foi
nesse conhecimento para melhorar as
nossas vidas por exemplo tentar
descobrir fármacos que a inclusão dos
mesmos benefícios que as alterações de
dna induzem um rato tocaram na bola área
até mesmo um futuro mais infantil
através da terapia gênica e nós temos já
que a fármacos nos permitem controlar
alguns viram animais à mesa tanto forma
conjunta uma nutrição isso tem um
impacto do envelhecimento não tem um
impacto tão grande quanto a genética
existem certas 500 que brandão
investimento em animais por exemplo a
restrição calórica calor que consistem
em diminuir a quantidade de calorias
escola mantendo minerais e vitaminas
roubadas mas na prática equivale a
plataforma é muito difícil isso com o
nosso relatório em que estamos a fazer é
desenvolver fármacos que induzam os
benefícios da restrição calórica sem ter
de fazer sessão pública na prática temos
os benefícios da dieta sem temos que
fazer dieta e buscar formas que aumentam
os que não têm animais só com disse não
como alterações de dna existe esse
mineira de ter aplicar esses
conhecimentos que estamos a descobrir
que os centenários e animais para
melhorar a vida humana e esse objetivo
temos filas mais longas e mais prováveis
e no futuro nós vamos conseguir
controlar o envelhecimento humano
vamos conseguir controlar o nosso tempo
filho mas sim em tudo
nós vamos viver mais vamos ter mais um
presente
estamos saudáveis em podemos aproveitar
esses anos não queremos perder mais
tharson um presente já estamos tão
rápidos que vão viver mais tempo
mantemos por souto e com base nos
estudos em animais é isso que vamos
conseguir fazer em seres humanos que ver
filas mais longas e mais uma vez que o
que todos queremos que as mãos e chuvas
e pessoalmente eu faço minhas as
palavras do estilista americano que diz
eu espero morrer consciente das
habilidades morto por um tiro de um
marido ciumento